well Tobias Elwood joins me now uh
Tobias Elwood um I was going to say I'll
watch this uh video
um let's take a little look at parts of
it and I'll come to you after that
all that's happened here since 9 11.
this is a very different country India
it feels different now that the Taliban
have returned to power well it may be
hard to believe that security has vastly
improved corruption is down and the
opium trade has all but disappeared
pylons distribute electricity to the
city's solar panels are now everywhere
powering irrigation pumps allowing more
crops to grow you quickly appreciate
this war weary nation is for the moment
accepting a more authoritarian
leadership in exchange for stability
well here in Cabool the streets are
relatively safe the checkpoints have all
gone businesses are reopening the
starting to function
s when I watched it I thought it might
be a spoof because it sounded and looked
like some kind of thing Alan Partridge
would do with the cheerful music uh you
sort of portraying the place now as a
safe haven everyone can Trot down to do
you regret with hindsight putting out
that video and the way you put it out
yeah um thank you for inviting me on
it's important to put your hand up and
acknowledge errors however
well-intentioned uh you and I have
spoken many times I stand up I speak my
mind I try and find Solutions especially
on the international stage
and I'm very very sorry that my
reflection of my visit could have been
much better worded and have been taken
out of context I have written
subsequently about the wider issues
there I mean the background is this as I
think you're aware I lost my brother in
the 2002 Bali terrorist bombing that
Drew me to visit the country many times
over the last decades understand what we
were doing but sadly see the demise of
the efforts there
um and uh I understand that the whole
issue of Afghanistan remains very raw
especially with the veterans who serve
after our departure and during the visit
last week I was astonished by what I saw
I went to something I did not expect to
see an eerie calm a visible change in
security corruption and an opium growth
which I felt obliged to report and could
have been better reported absolutely but
I also saw a very vulnerable economy and
this is the important point that will
collapse without International
intervention there's no doubt about it
it'll turn the country back into a
failed State okay but
you and I have talked as you said many
times about a number of issues right
normally you've been a smart Observer
and commentator on uh stuff that's going
on around the world I just think this
time you just seem to have uh lost all
perspective of how this was going to
play out with people I don't think I've
ever seen anything quite like this video
for the reaction is provoked You've Got
The Spectator which is a conservative
magazine uh calling you uh basically a
Taliban useful idiot
um you've got MP standing up in the
Commons on all sides condemning what you
were doing you've got the Prime Minister
distance himself from what you were
saying you've got people like Bill Neely
one of the great foreign correspondents
that this country's ever had saying an
astonishing piece of propaganda utterly
ignores the rights of lost life chances
of half the population not to mention
them a disregard for ethnic minorities
despised by the new rulers maybe to buy
us over reconsider his analysis once his
heat stroke has passed and then you had
other respondents talking about this
incident which happened in the last 24
hours a group of women come out on the
streets of cabal today to protest
against the taliban's closure of all
beauty salons in Afghanistan they
chanted bread work Justice the Taliban
used water cannons and gunshots to
disperse the protesters and you know one
of the many things you say in your video
you talked about potentially using
women's right to some kind of bargaining
tool with the Taliban which caused
complete outrage because women's rights
should never be used as any kind of
bargaining tool they should be afforded
because they're entitled to women's
rights do you I mean at the very least
on that point would you like to have the
opportunity to withdraw that
well you've made so many points today
maybe I could have an attempt to respond
you know the strategy that we have at
the moment from shouting from afar is
clearly not working we abruptly
abandoned the country in 2021 and my
simple call to action was to see our
Embassy reopen just as the EU Embassy
has opened as well and we need to pursue
a more direct strategy if we are serious
about helping the 40 million people who
feel abandoned I I understand that there
is a natural inclination given that
taliban's ruthlessness its
interpretation of sharia law it's
tripping to women and girls and in the
immense sacrifice that we made uh with
our brave service Personnel you know to
distance ourselves and to say no we're
not going to have any truck which I
think is what you're implying but the
awkward truth that we felt faces that we
handed power to the Taliban we seated
that power we abandoned those 40 million
people we said we're willing to commit
and help and if we are serious about uh
returning there in any form whatsoever
to provide support that requires
engaging openings do you accept that
women's rights should never be a
bargaining tool
it I I would absolutely agree that that
would be our position I'm making it
clear of what I believe the taliban's
position is which we then need to make a
judgments with respect to bias why
should we give us stuff about what the
Taliban thing there are a bunch of
videos they're a bunch of hideous
misogynists who have taken the country
in terms of women's rights back to the
Stone Age quite literally actually in
some cases women there are being
oppressed on a daily basis
and you're talking about using women's
rights as a bargaining tool I'm simply
saying surely on reflection you wish you
hadn't said you need to let me finish
you need to let me finish Pierce
otherwise I won't be able to get my
point across okay firstly this is the
Taliban that I'm saying I'm reporting
that's what I saw happening is the
Taliban are wanting to use this as a
bargaining tool they clearly don't care
about women's rights the certainly the
hardliners don't and there is Sun within
the Taliban itself that many of them may
Splinter away and join Isis K that's why
we're seeing more restrictions coming in
what we're also seeing is the situation
with with women's with girls education
is actually worse when I discovered half
the children under the age of 11 don't
go to school at all
I'm trying to interrupt but if it's
worse than you discovered how on Earth
could you put yourself to a promo video
with all that cheerful music about what
great guy is the talibana I just don't
get it
well you can keep referring back to the
video sir I made it very great you put
it out that was my error but I've
written further than that I could only
say so many things uh in in that video
and I make it very very clear I put my
hand up and say it could have been much
better done but I've also seen very
clearly too that our current strategy
that we're adopting at the moment is
allowing the Taliban to then run this
country in a way without any influence
whatsoever because they're not listening
you say okay but look you say the
Taliban are doing everything to ensure
the prosperity of Afghanistan is people
that's just a total lie they're not
what I'm saying is is that if we want a
we are serious about supporting women's
rights if we're serious about getting
those schools reopened then there needs
to be quiet engagement the shouting from
afraid is not working in fact I'm
just saying that yours your statement
that they're doing everything to ensure
the prosperity of Afghanistan and his
people and they're no longer a terrorist
organization those statements simply
aren't true they're consorting with lots
of terrorists
I never said that they were there were
never a terrorist organization never
used those words they were the this was
the very organization that harbored the
very people that killed my brother so
please don't put words into my mouth
okay if we want to have a serious debate
an awkward difficult debate of where
Afghanistan is going we spent more time
talking about Afghanistan in the last
couple of days because of my visit that
I'm pleased about and absolutely yes I
put my hand up and say that that video
could be done better you can keep
returning back to that video as much as
you like that doesn't actually get us
back to the bigger point of what we are
doing internationally to help women and
children in that country given the
reaction to the video which is actually
as you know something that you put into
the public domain uh clearly had no idea
the reaction was going to provoke or you
wouldn't have done it but given the
cross-party fury about this given the
media theory about this given the fury
of so many people in Afghanistan given
there's now a report in the times that
there's a a plot currently being
undergone to remove you from your
position of chair of the defense
committee will you be considering your
position
I'm traveling with the defense committee
here in India where I am right now and
we've you know we're we're working very
well together there is no support for uh
any of what is going on back in the UK I
make it very clear I don't know how many
times I can say this to you pierce you
keep returning back to it you don't
allow us to move on I put my hand up you
know I step forward on many occasions
and say things perhaps which other MPS
won't say and occasionally yes I say
things the wrong way because of Twitter
a storm then comes about about it and I
have to deal with it I'll be very clear
the last couple of days have probably
been the most miserable as a member of
parliament I got it wrong peers I don't
know how many times you'd like me to say
that but I stand by the fact that
Afghanistan is in a very bad place the
economy
difficult questions okay can I suggest
something will you delete the video
I'm happy to do so sir I'm absolutely
happy when you do that immediately this
interview is over because that would
indicate you genuinely are remorseful
of course I am and I would not refer to
do that I'll then put it on a cloud
station clarification of a statement to
do so but there is an underlying message
uh that we've not spoken about
Afghanistan I don't know when you last
brought it up on your program it has
been abandoned the diffid budget for the
United Nations
with respect you haven't got a lecture
me about Afghanistan my brother was a
serving British Army currently served
Tools in Afghanistan so I'm very aware
of Afghanistan I've covered it uh a lot
over the last years I was extremely
critical of the way we withdrew uh with
the Americans from Afghanistan it was a
total debacle but I also happened to
think the Taliban are a bunch of
Ruthless wolves who have taken with any
of them the poor women of Afghanistan
back to the Dark Ages nothing
unfortunately you got used in some way
which provoked you to do that video
which has looked like it was promoting
the talibat which I think was a
catastrophic error of judgment and I've
known you a long time I'd rather be
straight with you and tell you that I
think if the best thing you could do is
to finish this interview and delete that
video I'm gonna explain why you deleted
it I think that would go a long way to
putting people's minds at rest so you're
not some Taliban stooge which is how
people view it
yes it still doesn't answer the question
and I will do all that make that very
very clear as to what is our strategy to
help the 40 million people who feel
abandoned and we then ceded power to the
Taliban these are I'm afraid the awkward
questions that when everybody has moved
on from this storm right now we have to
still there are no yes I absolutely
agree there are very important questions
but doing a promo video for the Taliban
is not any way to go answering them so I
hope that you now delete it and explain
why you're doing that and I appreciate
you coming on and Dallas we'll talk
about other things another time
thank you